excuse me i'm very
very much naturally a loud speaker so if
anybody decides that they can't hear me
which i can't possibly imagine is true
let me know and i'll start using i'll
start using the mic
um i'm really excited to be able to to
be here and talk to you guys tonight
i'm going to talk about um one approach
at least
to large-scale etl processing
again my name is eric sammer i'm an
engineering manager at cloudera i've
been with cloudera
for about three years which in cloudera
dog years was a really long time
and uh i managed two different teams at
cloudera
one of which does uh what we call
partner engineering which is integration
with all of clutter's partners like uh
informatica syncsort
uh oracle dell hp and so on and so forth
as well as bi vendors and then the other
team is a new team that we just built
out
that's actually building a software
development kit
for building data processing
applications and systems on top of
what we would call the platform which in
our case is
uh hadoop mapreduce hive pig hbase
flume scoop uzi all these other systems
i'll tell you a little bit more about
that a little bit later um
but uh for now i just want to kind of
dive into things
so um i i always like to
to say that etl is like rest or disaster
recovery
and what i mean by that is that
everybody defines it differently and
everybody loves to fight
about their favorite definition of what
it actually means
and then you get into the semantics of
no no that's elt
not etl and all that other good stuff i
uh i like to throw out my hands and
abstain from those discussions in
general
um but i kind of like to think about etl
or data processing or data engineering
as more of a problem solution space than
any one specific thing it's a practice
it's a discipline um and it's not a
particular piece of technology
it turns out that it's really hard to
generalize etl or
data processing or data engineering
without being lossy in some way
and what i mean by that is a lot of the
general purpose systems out there in the
wild and i've used
all of them uh at some point or another
so for instance systems like spring
batch or
the the commercial etl tools maybe to a
lesser extent but
a lot of the open source ones that i
think you can go and look at today
um kind of go one or two ways when they
talk about
etl or building data processing
pipelines either they're
hyper generic in that they basically say
give me a blob of code with a main
function
and i will call it when it's time to
call it and i'll
set all kinds of environment variables
excuse me and pass in that the
information you need and
you sort of run in my little bubble or
they're hyper specific
and they say write a function that
operates on a single record
and i will do all of the other stuff to
make sure that that gets called in the
right order so like spring batch winds
up looking very much like that
um it's really hard and it's not that
either one of these are bad
it's not that the commercial etl tooling
is bad or the traditional commercial
egl tooling is bad it's not that spring
batch is bad it's just that it's a hard
problem to generalize
just generally um and people
at syncsort for instance spend an awful
lot of time thinking about how to do
this
make it efficient and not make it either
overly generic or overly specific
but it's still a problem but worst of
all
and and this is the thing that kills
probably all of the people who cut your
paycheck
um is that at face value it looks really
simple you get to file a bunch of
records you need to tear them apart and
build another file with a bunch of
records no problem right
you know turns out it's really
complicated in practice
because of all the other stuff that
happens around
etl jobs so really what
makes etl heart and
again this is my highly opinionated talk
so these are what things i think makes
etl heart
it's not hard anymore because
of the ability to perform some function
on uh
record a and produce record b that's the
thing that hadoop for instance is really
really good at
you know it gives you all the
infrastructure to be able to do
function of a producing b at scale
that's kind of the only thing it does
but that's the thing that it does really
well
um i think data integration or ingestion
in general is a hard problem and it's
really easy when you have a single
source
when you have a web a web server or five
or ten or five thousand
that are all spitting out logs and all
need to go someplace
fine that's kind of easy i'm talking
about people that have
that and then somebody comes on and goes
well you know we also use google
analytics
yeah and we also have this legacy
process for core metrics but it only
applies to this one
site over here and it's a micro site and
that site's kind of going to go away and
come back
and we're going to rename it and it's
going to go from
this to that and we're going to redirect
all the urls oh yeah we also want to
bring in
email marketing data or we're partnering
with experian to do data set enrichment
and like you kind of go like wait can i
just get like the web server logs in
and in the right format before we start
with all that nonsense so that's sort of
what i mean by data integration
data organization management and
monitoring
and now i'm really doing it uh not
justice by referring to it as just three
words with commas in between
it's really all of the infrastructure
about building these processing
pipelines and being able to
say all data from all ad servers
has arrived for the last hour turns out
that's actually a hard problem at some
level
knowing that you have all events that a
website hasn't died
or didn't send that one file or
accounting for bad records or all these
other things that wind up happening
so you get into things like data quality
monitoring and all this other
infrastructure around it so when people
say like yeah you know my etl
stuff it's just a it's a handful of
python scripts why so hard
and i kind of go like you know here's
white hard and i walk over to a web
server and i pull out an ethernet cable
and like they have no idea that that
happened so
you know weird things start happening in
real
large scale etl and i'm talking about
large scale i'm not talking about
i have one process it runs hourly and i
kind of i can stare at cron logs and
find out if it ran or not
i'm talking about large-scale etl
hundreds of thousands of
different data sources or even just
hundreds of data sources
all coming together process
orchestration and scheduling as two
separate disciplines
process orchestration being what people
refer to
before things like managing process a
produces data that is required by b
which produces data that's required by c
and then c and d can run in parallel and
then i want to wait until they converge
and join again
there are open source tooling things
like uzi that do this today
but um it's still a really hard problem
dealing with
you know synchronization and failures
within those pipelines and things like
that
and scheduling man if general purpose
scheduling
as a service in the data center it's not
a really hard problem and it turns out
that most people either punt and go
well i just have 5000 entries in my cron
tab for each user
or they kind of build embedded things
like quartz
into a bunch of different processes i
know airbnb
recently announced kronos which is an
open source thing that's kind of like
cron on steroids and with some
additional bells and whistles that's a
little bit closer to what i'm talking
about
and for you folks that are in like that
the enterprise space
um who work in cubes and things like
that
those uh those folks are familiar with
systems like uc4
which is a very very large enterprise
class builder-proof scheduling
distributed scheduling system
um distributed meaning that i create and
manage
jobs and processes in one place and in
that central
place i say this process runs on that
machine
or the other machine if it's not
available once an hour and i need you to
tell me
if it's you know out if it's running
slow and it's not going to make its sla
and all that other stuff
general platform accessibility and by
accessibility what i mean is the ability
for a new developer five days in
to come in and either modify or add a
process
um for many people
etl is like
it's you know building your own etl
platform is like a rite of passage if
you're a ruby developer
like hello world is like building your
own blog if you're a data engineering
person hello world is like building your
own etl platform
um and everybody kind of um of the
people i
poll everybody has built one they all
agree that they don't like any of the
ones that already exist
but they would never package and sell
you theirs
so they kind of hate that one too
so it's really interesting but at the
end of the day it's really about how
this all fits together
that's that's really the tricky part so
how many people in the room are familiar
with hadoop today
okay so uh hadoop is made up of two
giant pieces i'm not going to go into
details there's hdfs the distributed
file system it's a big bit bucket
and it looks like a file system
and mapreduce which is specifically
geared towards batch oriented data
processing at scale
so the ability to perform that function
of
a producing record b with
all of the well most of the necessary
scaffolding around it
the hadoop ecosystem supplies a bunch of
additional
infrastructure that excuse me most
people want
so for instance things like higher level
languages and abstractions on top of
mapreduce
because all it takes is you to implement
join
in low-level java mapreduce once before
you never ever want to do it again
it's really terrible so some of those
higher level languages are things like
hive and pig and cascading and crunch
and again this is a place where we see
a lot of the traditional etl vendors
again people like syncsort people like
informatica
pentaho building an integration to push
down
to mapreduce and sort of offload the
mechanics of executing that function and
things like that
of course with their own specialization
on top of it but this is one place we
see a lot of integration
um file relational and streaming data
integration
those are the three main buckets that i
i tend to think about you have files
that arrive as
files and they need to be moved around
as files the order of the records is
important
and the the fact that they are a batch
grouped together is also
important streaming data ingestion
or integration on the other hand is
where order of those
events is not important and the fact
that they are in files together
is not important it's a pragmatic way of
moving them
and that's where systems like
flume and kafka and scribe
do very very well in moving those events
in
high bandwidth scoop is uh
one open source project that basically
lets you point at relational database
tables or even a full database and say
all those tables put them in hdfs or put
them in hbase
it's very good at exactly that and the
inverse
sending them the opposite direction but
that's pretty much all it does
um there are tons of other things as
well
uh process orchestration and scheduling
this is where we have systems i
mentioned before we have things like uzi
azkaban is another popular one kronos
i think i don't know if it actually has
the orchestration side but it definitely
is the scheduling side
there are plenty of other systems out
there like that
one place that we don't actually talk
very much about but
libraries for parsing and text
extraction
i really think that like if you're
writing regexes day in and day out like
that gets old really really fast and you
kind of need a better solution
over time the ability to compose regular
expressions or compose
parsers even more so than just regular
expressions
so there's apache tikka that is
very very good at doing things like
taking a pdf
doc or an html dock and knowing how to
tear it apart
into uh individual features but
not so much on the individual record
parsing
there are libraries like grok which is
part of logstash that is very good at
taking named regular expressions and
tearing things apart
um i'm always curious to hear like
what other people use here because i
don't have like a good
three bullet point list here or a three
item list
these days uh uh low latency sequel
engines
on top of hadoop are all the rage and
everybody's got one
um including cloudera so ours is called
impala
and it's a traditional mpp style query
engine
very much follows the dremel google
dremel slash google f1
uh in fact the guy who built f1 uh works
at clutter
and is the tech lead on impala so
impala doesn't use mapreduce it's open
source
and you get to run low latency sql
queries and
the nice thing about impala is that it
has no file format per se
so you can map impile tables over things
like text files
or protobuf files or actually avro files
and things like that and it will do the
parsing uh on the fly while it's
clearing records
so i guess at a high level and when i
kind of
zoom out a couple of levels and i look
at the problem
um i kind of said like well really like
the question is how do you scale etl how
do you go from having one python script
to having hundreds of thousands of like
moving parts in this
big distributed system which is
effectively what etl is it's distributed
systems
with a strong bent towards data
integration i mean that's really what it
is
so to truly scale etl you do need to
separate the infrastructure
from the processes and the
infrastructure are things like
retry semantics and monitoring and
enqueuing and t-queuing and all the
other stuff around it
the processes are job 17 that's
responsible for web sessionization and
things like that
but you also need to make it a macro
level service
inside the data center and by macro
i mean it's a service composed of many
smaller services and those smaller
services
of etl are things like a process
repository
once you start getting big enough you
need a way
a standard way of deploying
individual data processing jobs or
pipelines or whatever you decide to call
them
and a way of executing them within that
repository
versioning them within that repository
you need
centralized metadata you really need
centralized metadata the notion that how
to parse
a web record or event being hard-coded
and being split on tabs and then index
you know
17 positions into the array to get the
user agent
that doesn't fly at scale you really
need metadata-driven
processes you need centralized
scheduling
and you need scheduling separate from
process orchestration
you need a system that can generate it's
12 o'clock onto a pub sub
you know broken broker system that
anything that cares about
doing something at 12 o'clock can listen
to wake up
and react to but those are separate
systems
you then need process orchestration so
that when you get that pulse
you know it's time to fire off a
workflow and to step through that state
machine
and you definitely need integration
adapters uh or
channels and this is where systems like
syncsort and informatica
have a lot of experience about creating
pre-approved
connections to a relational database and
then being able to grant
access to some group of developers to
that channel
so that you can actually create a set of
connections
and be able to grant privileges or
revoke privileges
to those adapters or channels and the
adapter side is really
a system or a chunk of code
that knows how to grab files from ftp
or files from sftp or ssh or
files from a web service you need
adapters for all these different
transports
you absolutely cannot survive without
both
service and process level
instrumentation
and metric collection if you can't tell
me how long it takes
to process you know an hour's worth of
sessionized
log data then you don't know what
happens
when the business guys run a campaign
that doubles traffic
right and if you don't know how many
records per second
you can handle then you don't know how
much hardware to buy
and you don't know what you're actually
doing in production so if you don't have
this information
and it's not centrally collected and
available and on a dashboard
that you can leave open all day you're
you're going to be in for some trouble
and the last one i like to throw around
which i think is
a lot of people think it's a nice to
have but i think it's it's a hard
requirement
is policy-based data management and by
this what i mean and this gets back to
separating infrastructure from
jobs or processes um policy based
data management to me means that on
a named data set like sessionized log
data
i can attach a policy that says retain
365 partitions of data if i add
a 356 lop off the oldest one
right that shouldn't be something that's
encoded into each individual job
because each developer will get it wrong
in a slightly new and interesting way
i say this from experience um
and i'm not talking about junior
developers i'm talking about when i get
it wrong
um so i really think that policy based
data management
is also things like your data pipeline
monitoring folks and that might also be
you who develops it
should be able to say huh we're running
low on disk space
i want to store all data in the most
recent
seven partitions in snappy and i want
you to compress
everything older than that in gzip
that's a policy decision
that's not a code thing where you're
messing around with io stream's decision
that's something that you should set and
tag on the data set and be done with
and if you have the right infrastructure
you can do that
so that's really pie in the sky
and no one has all of those things
that's my wish list if anybody's
thinking of getting me something for
christmas
um so what do we have today well
at the core the nucleus we have hdfs and
mapreduce
these are building blocks they are not a
complete etl system
and i work for cloudera hadoop is not a
it is the execution engine and the
storage for data
that's all it is you really need all
this other stuff around it
we have systems like flume we talked
earlier about kafka
for streaming event data ingestion
again if you're on the enterprise side
oracle golden gate
informatica power exchange i don't know
the syncsort stuff all that well but
you know things like that um
scoop uh if you don't have something out
of the box
it's a great place to start batch
exchange of relational database tables
with very very basic change data capture
right grab me all records in table a
that have been modified in the last or
since the last time i ran
you know and that's what i mean by
change data capture uh again the
enterprise folks know what i'm talking
about that's why i say that
um and scoop also like i said does the
opposite you can take a data set
in hdfs or an hbase table or a hive
table which is really just a data set in
hdfs
and you can materialize it in a
relational database as a table
again uzi and these are things that i
work most frequently with
this is just kind of my list that you
you'll be able to find
other other open source projects and i'm
very bent towards the open source side
here
for fear of accidentally plugging the
wrong partner or something like that
but uzi gives you process orchestration
it's basically like uh
i i almost hesitate to bring it up it's
been 10 years since anybody really
talked about it but uh bpm or or
business project
business process management you know
there's a bunch of people going oh don't
mention bpm well yeah
it's got uzi's kind of like a bpm light
um
and uh for those of you who have no idea
what i'm talking about you're in good
luck
you're probably under the age of 35. um
and again uzi gives you basic scheduling
it's basically got cron
cooked into it or uh quartz cooked into
it
uh if you don't know quartz it's
actually a really really nice java
library that does really nice scheduling
and
firing of events and stuff um and
some people have asked me like where do
you think like a low latency sql query
engine fits in
i don't think impala is something that
you should write etl pipelines in
in fact excuse me i'm pretty adamant
about sql not being the right way of
doing etl
i think it's it's really bad at that
it's bad at representing hierarchical
records and like all this other stuff
that you want
rich data structures but i think that
impala
and low latency sql query engines in
general
do have a good role in etl about doing
things like managing the metrics that
come off of jobs
being able to quickly uh look at samples
of the data for quality purposes um to
quickly compute standard deviation of
columns a b and c
um and things like that so i think that
they they do have a role here
um very specifically i i want to call
out
mapreduce um and the way i like to
describe mapreduce is that it's kind of
like the assembly language of data
processing
um think compete can poke well i guess
that's not assembly but you get the idea
um and if i had to give it a slogan
the slogan for mapreduce is almost
certainly
simple things are hard but hard things
are possible
so it's kind of good you know like yeah
that's that's kind of the
the the sales pitch for mapreduce
um compared to most things it is very
low level
you operate on a record and you can tear
that record apart and you can
output different types of records but if
you talk
if i were to sort of walk you through
how you join
two data sets giving given just
the mapreduce primitives it's pretty
gross
and you never ever ever want to do it
for anything other than
a weekend learning exercise
at least in hadoop mapreduce java level
knowledge
and an intermediate java level knowledge
is
is kind of the the price of entry you
really do need it
so in general if someone were to ask me
i would say
use higher level tools when possible
mapreduce is fantastic for compiling
down to
and if you're a systems builder it's a
fantastic
target language but or target
environment
but you don't want to be implementing uh
java mr jobs um for for
anything of modest complexity or
moderate complexity
so by high level tools pick your poison
you can if you like to do etl and sql
and
that's cool with you and you can read
nine level deep nested sub selects which
i
my brain pops i can't do that
you can use things like hive if you
if you already have commercial tools
like syncsort or
informatica or oracle's odi and things
like that
then those all of those tools that i
just mentioned can push down to
mapreduce
in various ways and can use the
mapreduce framework
and you should use those if you want to
speak
pig you can speak you can speak pig um
but definitely pick a higher level
language and if you want to write java
and there are cases where you do where
you have nine billion user defined
functions or you're doing spatial
processing and like you really need to
reach into your grab bag of tricks
then use one of the higher level
abstractions on top of mapreduce
like crunch or cascading or scooby or
skull
scalding or any of those guys
but i i really want to talk about data
organization
in hdfs because you know even with
having all those things
you know what we're giving you is a
distributed file system
and we're asking you to do data
management inside of that
and you know one thing the relational
database world has done
is kind of forgot you know sort of
taught us to forget
how to manage data in files you know
we've actually
it's sort of like if you drop me in the
woods i probably can't build a campfire
because i'm just too used to turning the
little dial and having fire come out on
my stove
not that i use my stove but if i did
that's what would happen
so going back to using files
for data management is actually a
challenge for a lot of folks
so what i'm going to do is i'm going to
give you my
sort of go-to design for sort of doing
this
um we will wind up using standard file
system tricks to make operations atomic
so basically to mimic things like
committing data sets
and doing batch commits and stuff like
that
we'll do fancy things with atomic rename
operations inside the file system
people who have been doing unix stuff
for a long time will recognize these
things
and when i want to commit a batch of
files in in unison or atomically
i'll write them to a directory off to
the side and then i'll rename that
directory into place and i'll do all
sorts of things like that
but i really think you need to use a
well-defined structure that supports
tooling all these monitoring processes
and i'll show you what i mean
so again this is a straw man proposal
but in hdfs my sort of go-to hierarchy
i start with um a file system
hierarchy that starts with the intent
of the data set what i'm trying to
convey
to users either producers or consumers
of a data set
the category of that data set the
application and maybe that's optional
that uses
that data set if it's a private data set
the actual data set name
the equivalent of a table in a
relational database and then i might
have
data partitioned into separate
directories for things like
effectively partition pruning or
poor man's indexing and then at the at
the leaf node i have actual files
so to give you an idea about what i'm
talking about um
for public referenceable read-only data
sets
data sets that are sort of shared across
the organization
i'll dump them into data um the fraud
group might be the group using that data
set the fraud detection group hopefully
not the group
causing fraud and they might have a
transactions data set like credit card
transactions
and then data partitioned by year month
day and then sort of at the leaf
we've got here i'm showing avro files um
hanging out belief on the other hand
uh you might have data that is private
to individual groups
and you might have group directory in
the research group and they might be
training out model number 17
which is like their their application
name and they might have training
transactions they might have multiple
data sets
that go into that model you can uh
specify a directory for each data set
and again at the leaf we've got the
actual files
that contain the data so from this
i can actually build tools that do
things like
quota uh analysis by uh data set intent
or data set group and or the group
that's consuming the data set
and so on and so forth so i think that
having this kind of standard
organization
is a really good thing so what i want to
do is i want to show you a real
customer example and anonymized and it's
actually the union of a couple customers
so this is one customer that i worked
with at cloudera
and this is a real high-level
architecture of their
data infrastructure so on the left-hand
side we have
producers of data and these are various
services in the data center
they have syslog data so they basically
collect syslog off of every machine for
tens of
thousands of boxes within the data
center
they have application events these are
things like a user logged in
or user added items to a shopping cart
they have click stream events which is
just
everything that happened you can think
of these two as sort of being kind of
the same
although the application events are sort
of specialized or higher value
events and then they have point of sale
data and actually all of the
you know terminals at the checkout lines
they this particular customers
brick-and-mortar stores
um all of their cash registered
terminals are basically
you know internet terminals so every
item they get scanned generates an event
and then a checkout generates an event
and all that other stuff
um so in this particular case the event
looks sort of like
you know some headers which are just key
value pairs that have the application
id just a id for the application that's
unique
um the type of event um
an epoch time stamp and i have a whole
one hour
discussion around how you actually
manage time
in distributed systems and data
collection and processing systems
i don't have time for it today and then
the body is just a bite payload
of of data and some customers do more
structured stuff some do less
we're using flue with different channels
so syslog data goes into one channel
that is reliable or sorry unreliable but
in memory
very fast these channels are fully
reliable channels so that we do
guaranteed
event delivery and you see that they're
going into
directories in hdfs which is something
that fluent does natively
and you see that we have syslog data
being written to data
ops basis for the ops group syslog and
then partitions by your month
day and i think in most cases people do
hourly for high volume
stuff like that and then you might have
web core
data and web retail data if you have
different sections on the site you can
do binning and
partitioning on output and then for
point of sale data
this data was partitioned by country by
region by store number by
year month day and all that data was
being written in
but they also for various processes
needed
data from the web app database
specifically all of the customers
who had accounts on the website um
including shopping carts and things like
that
and they also had an enterprise data
warehouse i think in this case it might
have been
teradata or oracle exadata or something
like that where they had things like
inventory and pending shipping manifests
and things like that
these data sets were scooped out and
placed into
directories on hdfs as well
so this gives you a basic idea
of what i'm talking about when it's
talking about bringing all this data
together
um i also like the idea of structuring
data sets in
tiers and i'll get a little bit more
into that
but what i mean is structuring data
within a hierarchy
basically building a graph of data sets
where you have
data sets that uh
are derived from uh you know their
parent
and the the way you derive data set
uh b from data set a is via a data
processing pipeline
right so if you can think of it that way
you think of data as a graph
right and being generated so this is
actually one
step on the larger road to data lineage
and by data lineage what i mean is that
data set foo
is the child of data set bar and and so
on and
so forth the nice thing about this
is that you can actually build item
potent um
or or simple fault and rebuild
maybe not not important but simple fault
and rebuild
data processing pipelines in other words
when all hell breaks loose
and you realize that you calculated
total in the wrong way
you simply wipe out the drive data set
and based on your lineage information
you know how to regenerate it now that
means that your top root most data set
must be correct
right so i'm assuming that we get it
into the system in a reliable way
so for instance i like to think of tier
zero as raw data from source systems
and this would be data coming off your
web servers or from syslog
or from point-of-sale terminals there is
no transformation done on this data
step one get it onto disk reliably
before you start mucking around with it
and throwing data away
because then if you don't do that you
have what i like to call the tax audit
problem
which is that receipts are very low
value
you throw them away all year and then on
april 15th
you get the letter from the irs that
says you're being audited and all that
stuff that was no longer important is
now absolutely critical
right so i like to think of getting data
reliably on disk as being your first
order of business
and then tier one is derived from tier
zero
it's cleansed maybe it's normalized
maybe we correct
all the weird capitalization stuff from
user to enter data and we normalize it
into
you know regions and stuff like that but
um
you know beyond that we might have tier
two which is aggregated from one
and might be like uh summaries of all
events in five-minute windows or
30-minute windows that you use for
sort of faster report generation or
something like that this is very very
typical
the important thing is that you never
have circular dependencies in your data
just like in code circular dependencies
and data processing pipelines
is a nightmare to unwind because then
you can't do
fault and rebuild this guy depends on
lockstep of that guy
and like they get all weird and then you
have to do record by record fixes
and all this other nonsense so you
really want the
simple waterfall style
data set construction so
here on the left we have a sample tier
0 and on the right we have a tier one
and
we have three processes a web
sessionization process
uh event report aggregation process
and maybe inventory reconciliation you
know depending on what you're doing
and you can see that web sessionization
is taking
the core and retail data and joining
with
the database data from the user
information the account user accounts on
the website
and maybe it's joining grouping those by
time bucket and doing uh
uh envelope fall off or a
session closing and then building a tier
one data set
if any time i decide that i don't like
the results of this
or that i missed a file and i need to
reprocess
data i simply delete that directory and
i rerun the process
everything is completely reproducible
the same way in theory
maven is supposed to give you
reproducible java builds
we can argue about whether or not that's
true
but you can see that also your tier one
might include
directories that are destined for export
to other systems so
in this case uh and and working at
cloudera we wind up using hadoop as sort
of the
central data busing system as well in a
lot of ways
what i've shown you is really just kind
of the tip of the iceberg
but i think that these techniques make a
lot of sense and that
what i'm really trying to do is wrap
some uh reasonable practices and names
around i think a lot of the things that
we do today
you know and again like if you talk to
folks at syncsort and informatica
they'll go
yeah of course we've been doing that for
30 years right you know so like this is
this is all the infrastructure around
you know a simple python script this is
why i think etl is harder
in practice uh than than than a lot of
people giving credit for
um but there is a lot left to do we
really need to build libraries or
services and reveal higher level
interfaces
and i'm now i'm talking explicitly about
the hadoop stack in general
like it's pretty low level there's a lot
of sharp edges
and there's a lot of common practices
practices
that we and uh you know for building
processes that we can sort of knock out
pretty easily
um data management and life cycle events
i think you know is one of those things
that we just don't handle very well
i like to use messaging systems for
being able to know when new files are
added to data sets
and basically instrumenting the data
processing infrastructure
so that you can attach monitoring
systems and other downstream events for
that
but there's all kinds of stuff that goes
into
for instance managing evolving schemas
or you know dealing with upgrades to
you know file formats and you know all
that other stuff
and by life cycle events i mean a data
set is marked as no longer critical but
reten in a retention a cold retention
cycle or something like that
um instrumenting jobs and services for
performance and data quality
uh mapreduce counters are actually
really nice
for measuring data quality while you're
actually doing processing
so as you're tearing apart records you
count the number of instances of
records that look like this and records
that look like that and at the end of
the job you have the process data but
you also have a bunch of instrumentation
information that you can use for quality
metadata metadata metadata and also some
more metadata
um i think that you know being able to
have metadata
about the data sets schema information
who created it when it was created how
many partitions it has how big it is
all those receipts from the audit
problem like
all that stuff is critical but also for
applications
last deployment time number of data sets
generated by this
job knowing that data set 17 and tier
one
is actually the result of process
4 at version 0.5.9
right being able to do that lets you say
oh wow we found a bug in this java class
you know what data is impacted by that
and then you get into
what the enterprise guys call impact
analysis but like
that's the type of stuff that i'm
talking about when i talk about metadata
um process or or job deployment
service location you know where's the
job tracker in hadoop you know
where's the schema registry where is the
metadata service
things like that configuration of jobs
i every place i go into that sort of
hand codes etl processes and like python
or java or whatever
has like property files for this and
command line arguments for that
and environment variables for this one
really special thing and like
you know all that other kind of nonsense
you know so uh having a central way to
do that
so we looked at this at cloudera and i
am just so
sick of re-implementing this
infrastructure and every customer i've
ever visited
that i i made arguments to our ceo and
our vp of engineering and a bunch of
other people internally
and i said i really want to build a
developer kit
that simplifies a lot of and start
knocking out a lot of the stuff that
we're talking about and i don't mean
like go and build a complete monolithic
etl system to compete with the
enterprise vendors
because i think they do what they do
very well what i'm talking about are
some of these libraries some of these
missing names parsers and like all this
other stuff
that that we implement over and over and
over again so
um what i did and i started building a
team and they were lucky enough to give
me
give me some folks to be able to do this
was we started to build an open source
project
that uh is explicitly geared towards
simplifying the process
of building data processing applications
and systems on top of hadoop or on top
of what we would consider
the platform which is like the hadoop
ecosystem
so for instance you know or sorry
before i get into what we've actually
built this is really
for data engineers by data engineers so
i'm one of the main developers on it and
i've done this
for better awareness for a long time and
then there's a bunch of other people
inside of cloudera that are working on
this as well
tom white who is one of the map produced
committers
he works on my team he's the author of
hadoop the definitive guide
so we've got some real hadoop knowledge
behind
this particular initiative we've got
some other folks working on as well
but it's really you know kind of buy us
for us kind of thing
one of the things that i think when you
talk about building a development kit
you know docs examples guides are
an absolute must for a minimum viable
product
and and strong guarantees around
deprecation cycles and api compatibility
and what's a public interface versus
what isn't
we have bulletproofed all of this stuff
so to give you an idea of what we've
built we started with the data module
because this seemed like the easiest
thing to attack
and what it is is simplified data set
management in hdfs
so all that directory naming nonsense
that i just told you about
you never have to build that again
the other thing was an application repo
or an application management
set of apis for deploying these
processing pipelines and then executing
them
at a later date and again it's really
just
wrapping some best practices around hdfs
and things like that
another thing we're working on is
something called morph lines which is
uh because we didn't want to call it
pipelines and what it is is a library
to do that you can plug into
user-defined functions in hive or java
mr jobs
or even parts of your application
someplace else
it's just a small library that does
record filtering transformation
and pattern extraction from records uh
with like named patterns and things like
that
this is going to be integrated i'll
come back to a little bit more about
that um
that's a good question so um this is
uh just at a very very high high level
um what the data module winds up looking
like
and i'm not going to spend a lot of time
on i just want to sort of tour you
through some of the highlights
so we have this notion of data set
repositories
so here i'm using a file system data
repository which stores data in hdfs
or on your local file system and what
we've done here
is configured the file system we have
nice builders for everything
if you choose to use them or not we
specify a root directory and here i'm
using slash data that's going to be my
repository for data sets
and i create an instance of that
in the second section here i call repo
dot create
and i give the data set a name i call it
user events
and i use what's called a data set
descriptor where i specify a schema
we specify all schemas as avro it
doesn't necessarily mean the data is
stored as avro but we use this as an
in-memory representation of
types and fields and records and all
this other stuff
and i've specified a partition strategy
and the partition strategy is what
decides
by policy how you partition this data
set
so what i've done is i've said there's a
user id field
in the user event schema i want you to
do a hash
function of this mod 53
so that i bin users over 53 buckets so
it's just hash partitioning
um down here once that data set is
created
i get a writer object very sort of
traditional
java style apis not because i think that
this is the nicest way to do it but it's
the way that most people already know
so i want this to feel really familiar
we're going to
write avro generic records you can write
pojos you can write all sorts of stuff
i open my writer i create i use the avro
record builder with the schema
and i say the user id is one the time
stamp is whatever i want it to be
build the record write the record flush
the record
or flush the stream and then close it
and then on this side what you will get
from this block of code in hdfs or on
the local file system
is slash data which is our repo our data
set repository location
you'll get a user events uh directory
which is the
table name and under the hood and i'm
not showing it here i'm using the
default implementation
there's what's called a metadata
provider which is a plugin interface
that you can write your own plugins for
but the default implementation squirrels
the metadata for the data set
into a hidden directory in hdfs
so you see a schema.aggro or avro
schema file which has the serialized
schema and the descriptor.properties
file
that tells me all sorts of information
about the data set including
user-defined
tags and stuff like that and then
based on the partition strategy as i was
writing data in
the underlying libraries are making the
correct calls to create
the user id 0 bin and the user id 1
bin and writing the right records into
the right partitions
we handle all the file creation stuff
for you no you don't get to pick your
file names
why because it's an opaque api we do all
of the data set management for you
we'll probably open up some of that but
at least in the 0.1 release which is the
stage that we're at
this is what it does for you this works
today um
this is an open source system it is
available on github
today you can download it play with it
and use it
we've been working with the folks at
twitter on a new file format it's a
columnar file format
that we're using for impala called
parquet so by default
all of this stores data in avro
records so you can represent arbitrarily
complex structures
and it's snappy compressed by default
because
that's almost always what you want what
we're going to do in the next release
which is may
sorry may 2nd we're going to add avro as
an or sorry a parquet
as another option so you'll be able to
specify i want this data stored in
columnar format
so organized by column or a
record-oriented format
organized by record so
is park air going to be like similar to
high or exactly just really policy
i'm going to come back to questions and
stuff like that but yeah i'll come back
so to the contributors potential and
current in this ecosystem
we have a lot of work to do you know
hadoop as an ecosystem is is not is not
done that is for sure um there's still
way too much scaffolding
uh to have to build these data
processing uh infrastructure
and pipelines excuse me on top of this
platform
uh for people who do this um
but i'm roughly out of time uh for now
um although i'll talk your ear off if
you'll at me
um but i really want to answer your
questions so we'll do that stuff as well
make sure you check take a look at the
cdk if you go to github you can fork it
today it's apache license completely
open source
and we are very interested in pull
requests there's lots of guides about
contributing and things like that
um by all means send me nasty grams and
yell at me
on on twitter um and um
if you want to discuss the cdk we use
the
cdh the cloudera distribution for you
user mailing list
but you'll absolutely never remember
that url so
please just google it i've had
a lot of fun barking at you guys for 49
minutes and 52 seconds
and um if you guys have questions i want
to answer those today so
i know you had a question before what
was you your question was
so okay
so is cdk gonna enough some kind of ui
interview
so the question is will the cdk have
some kind of ui
in clutter manager for those not
familiar cloudera managers or management
product that runs on top of hadoop and
manages everything
today no the cdk is a bunch of java
libraries right now
um and it doesn't necessarily mean it'll
always be that
we definitely i definitely want to do
things like uh
you know better see implementations for
avro and stuff like you know there's a
bunch of stuff that i want to do
and maybe there's a ui component to some
of it
but um i think we really want all of the
stuff in the cdk to be open source
cutter manager is a proprietary product
so we probably wouldn't put it in
cloudera manager
hue or one of the other sort of ui web
things would be a more likely place for
us to put it but uh yeah
sorry and you had a question about this
parquet
so parquet is a file format so hive is
like impala has no particular file
format
um there is a calendar file format for
hive today called rc file
which is developed by facebook it's good
parquet is sort of a an improvement
on that and if you've ever looked at
the google dremel paper the file format
that they
described is effectively the parquet
format okay so it's repeated records and
var int packing and
lots of other fanciness yeah
you talked about uh your on your wish
list or you had a laundry list of things
for etl
process repository metadata repository
scheduling
process orchestration service and
process
instrumentation and then you talk about
flume scoop oozy
they do somewhere all of those things
right uh what about
the service and process instrumentation
you
is mapreduce counters you mentioned that
is that an about hole that's powering
out so if i could summarize
um the the question is of my laundry
list
which is the which is the component or
the project
or the product that handles the service
instrumentation and metric collection
stuff like that
um i think that that's a hard one
because it's uh
it's uh orthogonal to the functions of
the
of the actual processing pipeline so uh
and it's a cross-cutting concern
if you want to use that phrase um so
like logging and all this other things
you kind of want every process to have
this
and the only way i know how to do that
is to have some standard set
of support classes or
infrastructure built into the actual
execution framework so
to your point about do mapreduce
counters kind of
count and fill that void for mapreduce
based workloads
yeah i think that that's probably good
enough for most cases
the mapreduce framework kind of monitors
itself and has a lot of metrics there
you get per job metrics the problem
with mapreduce is that there's nothing
inherent in mapreduce jobs
that tie together related jobs that are
part of the same pipeline
so that's on you so like uzi may submit
job a followed by b followed by c
there's nothing
that actually ties those metrics
together
other than maybe you injecting a
property
that labels this as pipeline 5 or
something you know
so you need to be really diligent about
how you do that and the best way i know
how
for sort of hand coded
pipelines like that is uh to
have kind of like a framework for the
guts of a job you know but that's a hard
one
so i tend to use uh coda hales or the
yammer metrics library
excuse me has like histogram
functions histogram counters and like
all these other kinds of
things to be able to do uh you know
measurements at the job level
and you know i might use support classes
or delegates or
you know in some certain cases god help
me
uh abstract parent classes and stuff
like that when i when i feel the need to
use inheritance
um so there are a bunch of things that i
do there but it kind of depends on the
framework of the embryo
did you have a question yeah so that you
showed some processes between your tears
your yeah
zero how those processes you do in
memory
oh so the question is in the slide on
between tier zero and tier one data sets
the sessionization process and those
things
how are they actually implemented in
this case um and in the world i live in
most processes are mapreduce jobs where
or
you know a workflow of mapreduce jobs
and
those are potentially uh
spilling to disk and doing all sorts of
stuff so they're not strictly in memory
they're logical
but they're these big sort of like links
and normalization all this
migration uh yeah so we can do
normalization and cleansing all that
kind of stuff in that produce jobs yeah
and that's an asset like for speaking
about that informatica
so you can plug in directly or you still
need a scoopy
between like intermediate interface
between
so i'm not sure i understand your
questions so for for you need to process
the
setup ptl like right informatica
it's a directly on you need a scoop it
still oh
um so this mostly and again most of the
data sets that i work with
um are probably already written to
do by their source systems now
informatica and again my apologies to
the six
are friends of syncsort but uh
informatica is the one that i'm just
happy to be
a little bit more familiar with
informatica has two modes with their
hadoop support one is
you can treat hdfs as a source or target
in an informatica workflow or
it has what's called like a transparent
uh usage mode
where basically what it does is
informatica uses its existing
functionality to grab data out of like
oracle or something like that drop it on
to do
run the workflow and then pull it back
out of hadoop automatically and put it
in the right place
and that usually makes sense when
the total run time of the job it's
actually
makes sense to do that full export
process and then full
or full import run full export which it
doesn't always make sense to do that
yeah so it depends yep just as a
little nervous yeah so i'm with syncsort
so
but um just to add on what you're
talking about you know replacing scoop
we actually have like cop store uses
today
to replace scoop to load their hdfs and
hold about 75 terabytes a day
and they compress it and then they
actually sort it and then they loaded
so they we've got a number of customers
doing that yeah
okay any platform
so yeah so most when i said like most of
the enterprise like you know
major etl players uh syncsort
um informatica all these guys they've
got all kinds of infrastructure to
drastically simplify a lot of the stuff
that i'm talking about
um so part of this is
is actually you know for those people
you know
this talk i i give to those people and
say like you know what does it look like
to actually do etl or movie tl
from you know a proprietary processing
grid of like eight nodes
to a cluster of 800 nodes or something
like that so
uh anybody else yet uh so we use
counters within our
averages jobs to keep track of a lot of
metrics
do you ever find uh that well we find
that
sometimes we want to persist those
counters after the fact
right is there a slick way that you've
heard of
people doing that sure so the question
is um when you're using like mapreduce
counters for
for collecting metrics about jobs and
you want to persist
those metrics how do people do that
so in certain versions
there's actually a statistics file that
gets generated
and dumped into the user history logs
directory which actually
has a lot of job counter metrics in it
and they might have all of them
um the other thing
we used to do before that existed and
that's in cdh
version blah blah blah whatever i'd have
to look it up um
or since version whatever i have to look
it up
the other thing we used to do is there's
ultimately something that's actually
submitting the job to the job tracker
right when you submit that job as part
of the infrastructure that knows whether
that job succeeded or failed
you are inherently blocking or have some
call back
waiting for that to complete the job
info object
you get back from the job tracker allows
you to grab the counters and then you
can persist them
in some way and if you build like sort
of standardized launcher infrastructure
one of the items on my wish list which
turns out i'm gonna have to build
you know because nobody's buying it for
me
is one of the things that we'll do is
that we'll kick off a job and then we'll
grab the counters and then we'll
hand them back to somebody to persist
somewhere
yeah um as you said the issue that we
see more and more is data management
you know either or in my second or any
kind of database and once this
issue that we see one more is you know
data retention
uh so is it something that you've seen a
good option to deal with or is that
something actually that
you plan on dealing with yeah
so the question is um you know with lots
of data management topics you get into
the
realm of data retention and how do
people do that and
do we plan on doing something like that
within the cdk
um i
i think data retention probably means
different things to different people
in a lot of cases there's that policy
aspect that says
as data gets older for some definition
of older
you might ratchet up the compression you
might down the replication factor you
might
do reed solomon coding or or something
like that
or you might ship it off to some other
long-term system
and so i think that if we had
centralized scheduling
and we had you know instrumentation to
know when you add new partitions
that scheduler would kick something off
that says it's time to see
if i need to migrate data off in clutter
manager
we have what we call bdr which is a
business disaster recovery i actually
forget what the acronym stands for
but what what it basically does is
schedule movement and archival
of data sets usually to another cluster
though yeah
but which is what a lot of our customers
do because it turns out hdfs
is pretty cheap storage for a lot of
that stuff
um so usually so the question is uh i
mentioned
impala for data quality measurement or
or inspection do we tie it into the
process or do it after the fact
there are two ways i see it being used
one is
excuse me because all of those data sets
in hdfs can be queried directly with
impala because it doesn't have its own
file format
you can effectively map a table
definition
over all of those data sets and query
them
at any point right so what i would do is
i would actually create table
definitions for every one of those and
the cdk
creates those data set definitions by
way of its metadata provider plug-in
it can be configured to create data
table definitions in hive
in the hive metastore which impala uses
the idea being that
you would build dashboards that maybe
run
some sql query every 30 minutes over the
last
you know however much data in each data
set and build like distributions of
values and
how many missing records are that you
know things like that
so if if you have a tool like impala
that can actually query any format
and you have all of your data in hdfs
then you can basically just
touch any data set from any etl pipeline
at any time
and build dashboard real-time dashboards
on top of that so usually that's what i
would do
yeah i would definitely build checks
within within the flows themselves as
well and normally
you have sort of different levels right
one is
a record is bad and you might use
counters to count that if the counter
gets above a certain size you
throw an exception which causes the job
to fail which causes uzi to retry it or
page you or something like that
the other way to do it is the other
level is to monitor the jobs
themselves see if the job's complete if
the jobs don't complete again they fail
they paid somebody
i think with the general purpose
scheduler one of the monitoring things
that i like and the thing i like about
the standard directory layout
is that for partition data sets by time
which
with the schema information and some
metadata you have that information
you can say that if the daily date daily
directory
doesn't show up by 20 minutes after
midnight
page somebody right like you can
actually build like halting style
uh checks to make sure that everything
that you know the big machine is working
as
as expected so i would actually use the
directory structure to know
not only which directory was missing but
you know
when the time stamp of the last created
directory and all that other good stuff
about the data lineage issue like that's
basically making sure everything has
some sort of audit trail right
yeah so data lineage has a couple of
purposes one like i said is impact
analysis if you
discover so i had a bank and i can't
tell you which one
had a major bank come to me and say uh
we just got
fined like a couple hundred million
dollars by the fcc because our daily
total was wrong
and we don't know where we actually used
the wrong
field but somewhere we used the wrong
field so i get that
yeah writing raw data to tier zero yeah
makes perfect sense
yeah but i also know that probably a lot
of organizations pre-process the data or
batch it somehow or lose
like before they even write it yes
what's the real world pressure
that makes that makes uh someone like
build a system like that is just lack of
knowledge or
lack of storage or like what why do why
do they not write raw data to this
that's a great question so why do people
it's about the time most organizations
have data in tier zero it's already been
sort of mangled at some level
and why do people do that and stuff like
that there's a few reasons one
is that people new to hadoop are in this
sort of world of saving disk space
and stuff you know they're very geared
towards the space and resource
consumption problem
so they're very hesitant to say what do
you mean store all of it
like that's they're very skeptical of
that the other
uh is legacy processes right like
there's something that kicks the data
out and it's already looking like that
um so it's a lot of that and then yeah
people just don't think about it they go
like
well why keep the thing i don't need and
my answer is always
how do you know you don't need it you
just don't need it now right you know
and
the same way i don't need my car keys
right now but i'm probably going to
drive at some point in my life
you know so um it's easier to see the
criticality of things
and quite frankly the thing that wakes
people up is uh
when when they drop something that they
can't get back
i mean that's like that bank like where
they kind of went like hey like we have
no idea how
this number came to be and it's in the
excel spreadsheet but
you know where that came from is beyond
us um
that's the kind of thing where like a
couple hundred million bucks later
you kind of go okay maybe we should keep
everything like you know it's that level
um that doesn't always hit everybody um
and
and god bless those people but um
yeah i don't really know i don't really
know it's a federal regulation
you have to keep seven years of data
yeah it's a sardines actually
but it's funny because like it's only
sarbanes-oxley has like this weird
clause that says like you only have to
keep for seven years would you actually
generate
so the answer is well if i never output
it then i'll have to keep it
right so like people play games like
that like there's all this other
nonsense
has that become an archiving right say
after three years
yeah after five years it's archiving so
yeah compliance officer turns out
actually is a job title it's just not
the one i want
you know i heard a story about
ebay where they were transforming the
logs before they were
loading them and anything that then
transformed properly just got done
and there was some fraud case where
someone from the inside
yeah uh taught these people how to get
you know generate or generate their logs
so they would be
corrupt yeah i've heard all kinds of
crazy
willy-nilly stuff about data any
other questions about this stuff yeah
yeah what's the best way to handle small
files on http what's the best way to
handle small files on hdfs
you have a couple of options one is
and this is where i think policy gets
into it is that
write the small files to hdfs and then
have a policy
connected to a scheduler that wakes up
and says anything smaller than
x i pull i bundle together right so
you basically just wake up and do
compaction um
and that seems to work really well and
you can do that
you know at some off time or you can do
that
at some later date but the data is
immediately useful
and then you deal with the the sort of
fact that you don't want small files
later on
um kick the can a little bit down the
road
how many tiers do people normally get to
in practice
um usually in the public like
enterprise-wide data sets
there's usually like tier zero and tier
one and
maybe tier two like the aggregated data
and
the ops group or the data management
group will say
for reports that only need five minute
granularity please use tier two you know
um and then you can see that like
uh the fraud group you know is tier
three
and then my home personal directory and
experiments tier four
so i mean like i've seen stuff when you
track full lineage
i've seen 10 15 tiers deep
of derived data um and usually drive
data might be a join between
you know tier five and tier seven and
like you know like it gets
complicated really fast um but uh
i would think in practice you don't want
to go 2d you know you want to have as
many of those data sets that you use
be central shared audited well-known
data sets
i think that that's critical i see
people
going with jackets on so what i'm going
to do is i'm going to rap now
and then if people want to sort of chat
about individual things i'm more than
happy to do that
guys thank you so much it was a real
pleasure for me